joining us now is senator tom cotton
uh who was part of this well i call it a
farce because all of these have become
politicized over the years
senator cotton
this point of this one case which i
decided to focus on it's an area of law
as you know for many years
the immigration law
that i think has been absolutely
bastardized
by
by activists and sadly judges
what does this tell us about her
judicial philosophy which she decided
she wasn't going to really address today
laura the case tells us that judge
jackson is a far-left activist
she always has been
just because she put on a black robe 10
years ago she didn't change as you
outlined
she took an immigration law that removed
all jurisdiction from the federal courts
for expedited removal the trump
administration acted on that law and she
still reviewed it and she still enjoined
the trump regulation nationwide
her court of appeals one of the more
liberal court of appeals in america said
that it was a blatant disregard for the
plain language of the statute it goes to
show that a far less left activist will
take the steps they want to achieve
their results there was another case
that i highlighted laura of a fentanyl
kingpin to use his own words she
sentenced him because of mandatory
minimums in 2018 to 20 years she
apologized at the sentencing hearing to
him she said she was sorry she had to do
so and shared his frustration he came
back two years later for a bogus
covet early release motion she denied
that as she had to but then she just
took it on her own initiatives to strike
seven and a half years from his sentence
which she never wanted to impose in the
first place
that's the kind of senator we actually
have a part of that i saw on display
from the last two days
senator just so people who didn't watch
the hearing today i want them to see
what you're talking about so they
understand how important this is watch
before you granted this fentanyl
kingpin's motion to reduce his sentence
did you contact any of the victims
senator mr young was not released
his sentence was reduced and i did not
contact the victims in this case because
there were no victims he committed
a crime a drug crime there were no
identifiable victims in his case
drug crime is not a victimless crime
i mean
we've had 51 000 overdoses i believe
just in the past year
most of them involve some level of
fentanyl overdose isn't that right
senator how do we call that a victimless
crime it is beyond me
yeah in the last full year that for
which we have data it was a hundred
thousand overdoses laura so that's not
just a hundred thousand victims but
hundreds of thousands of loved ones of
parents and husbands and wives brothers
and sisters children friends who are
being killed by the poison that is
largely coming in across our
uncontrolled southern border but judge
jackson like so many far less left
activists thinks that mandatory minimums
for drug crimes are too harsh just like
she apparently thinks that mandatory
minimums for child pornography are too
harsh she consistently sentences on the
lowest end of the sentencing guidelines
or even deviates downward from the
sentencing guidelines that's what we've
seen over the last two days examining
her record and she is a far-left
activist who always almost always finds
a way to sympathize with the criminals
not with the victims
a senator i just still can't believe
soul
unreviewable discretion
that's what the statute says in the
immigration case
and she refused just refused to apply it
and said oh no i can review that and
totally invalidate that uh
unbelievable senator it's astonishing
and as you said her court of appeals in
washington dc is not exactly a bastion
of right-wing thought it is one of the
most liberal court of appeals in america
and they have been repeatedly reversed
by the supreme court for engaging in
similarly egregious
decisions but even they said that this
was beyond the pale it was one of the
worst examples they had ever seen of
disregarding the plain language of the
statute i don't know how you can
misinterpret soul unreviewable
discretion
yeah senator thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else